hold up your hands give her your energy
yeah come on
how's it going bros before I do anything
in this vlog I have some very exciting
and important update for you as you may
know I wrote a book this book loves you
it's the greatest thing since baby Jesus
I am basically going to announce where
the book tour will be so if you want to
meet me and get the book sign or what
selfie or whatever you want to do pay
close attention the precise location
like which store is still a secret I
don't know why this is a stop but what I
can tell you is that the very first UK
publication event a big deal will be at
the 18th of October in London yes UK
pros get me first because I live in
London a UK this is the first
opportunity in the world to get to hold
my book this book loves you in your
hands and me in your hands if you are in
Leeds the October 24th my birthday you
get to meet me on my birthday in Leeds
the signing after that is October 25th
in Manchester so London Leeds Manchester
we start with UK so to make sure that
you get a place or in the signings
there's obviously going to be a lot of
people I'm kind of a big deal check out
the link in description and sign up to
participate once you have signed up you
will get your ticket and that will say
exactly where the location is we don't
want a bunch of freeloaders now if
you're a bro from USA don't worry I'm
going there as well it will be in New
York City Los Angeles and the Bay Area
all the info on that will be also fine
in the description I'm just so excited
for this tour I love meeting you Bros on
events it's always so much fun and I
can't wait
I honestly can't wait to meet you so
I'll check out a link in description
I'll see you down below good morning
first of all yeah boy number one in your
face minecraft in your face [ __ ]
second of all I'm gonna help out March
here today to do her pocket or project
that's cool yeah yeah yeah mine said
just finish her lines for her show how'd
it go really well you were awesome my
stomach at one point
yeah awesome okay well that was cool man
it took two hours so now we're gonna get
lunch we're having lunch meeting so we
can plug it but later you're going back
I have a live stream coming with that
all right
five minutes left I'm here with these
guys hi we're gonna do friendzone
celebrity yes and then we're gonna play
legend of the brofist this will be like
two days later so you will have missed
it probably but it will be the best show
ever
yes if you watched it good on you yeah
good for you come on livestream
say hi there's 20 people watching to her
play trying to beat this level you can
do it come on come on you doing else I
almost made it I'm giving you my spirit
bomb in me okay you're almost there it's
literally at the top of this you have to
do it you have to do it I'm giving you
my spirit bomb energy this friend
holding up my hold up your hands give
her your energy yeah come on here
you're never watching the livestream
hold up your hands Oh
make it happen come on for Adam time
Dodger she's milking it she's milking
she's no good honey
um-hum what are you doing you're dancing
great why is there a mess here
okay I just got back it is seven on a
Friday I worked all day - it was really
fun livestream was fun had my stuff was
fun but now I got a clean look at this
so clean people don't realize I'm the
woman in this relationship in the
non-sexist way whatever doing that works
there we go to cinema man the quality
associate okay or go into the Grove or
Grove and it's to dog you can't even see
Marissa is here somewhere that's scary
we're gonna watch a movie I'm too tired
and do it but and doing this week I'm
such a good boy so pretty at night we've
been here before but this is awesome
way too many people going on right now
but there's a cinema holy holy [ __ ] this
is a cinema
British cinema is like you sit in
someone's garage this is like we're so
being tourists right now timeline I like
her like hey pants as I know is legit
bro okay well nice meeting you guys yes
sitting outside the moon is there so
romantic
yes cinema semana
this food is amazing this mojito
I mean heaven it's so good hey Rufus I'm
she's calling me skinny this is great
first one ever oh my god I'm gonna be on
the show the first I told an over driver
and he just stared at me blankly like
who the [ __ ] are you I'm very excited
for very nervous
hope it's not [ __ ] on the north holy
crap so baby okay we watched a movie it
was really fun I'm just super tired I I
think we both almost fell asleep yeah
it's a good movie I like that alright
I'll end the prologue here thank you for
watching I'll see you tomorrow they'll
punch the camera what's happening